[Musique]
de somptueuses 403 pour vous mener
jusqu'aux portes du château de
rambouillet les flashs des journalistes
pour vous accueillir et un voyage dans
l'histoire à chaque pièce du château
voilà ce qui vous attend pour la
reconstitution historique secret défense
qui débutera en juin prochain samedi 26
mars avait lieu les premiers calages
techniques on va rejouer les coulisses
et la rencontre présidentielle qui s'est
déroulée ici au château de rambouillet
en 1959 entre le général de gaulle et le
général eisenhower tous deux étaient
alors président de leurs nations les
états unis d'amérique et la république
française
les spectateurs vont passer de pièce en
pièce pour découvrir ce spectacle ils
sont vraiment immergé dans l'histoire et
tout doit jouer comme dans un film ça va
être époustouflant pour les gens qui
vont venir voir ça et donc du coup en
amont on doit caler tous les détails
chaque personnage est important dans le
spectacle chaque personne exactement sa
place donc on doit qu'elle est tout ça
très minutieusement pour que le tableau
final soit exceptionnelle pour les
spectateurs
au total ce sont six cents comédiens
figurants ou encore chanteur qui feront
vivre l'histoire au détour d'une pièce
vous pourrez croiser charles de gaulle
jon irwin ou encore espions et diplomate
chacun et tient son rôle dans la
convivialité et la bienveillance faire
de l'histoire quelque chose qui nous
rassemblent et se retrouver autour de
l'histoire pour partager ensemble
quelque chose qui est bleu le vivre
ensemble l'aventuré humaine se
retrouvaient pour se rappeler de cette
époque dans ce spectacle là je suis jon
irwin le secrétaire d'état à la défense
eisenhower du président eisenhower en
plus de l'aspect artistique scénique et
de l'aspect historique c'est une
formidable aventure aventure humaine que
ça soit entre les acteurs les bénévoles
les volontaires mais également avec le
public parce qu on a des expériences
avec le public qui sont extraordinaires
c'est aussi avec le public avec les
volontaires avec l'équipe polaris avec
plein de choses parce qu'on apprend des
choses et on vit les choses ne serait ce
que dans vêtir le costume c'est vraiment
une vraie et belle histoire le spectacle
aura lieu sur quatre week-ends du
vendredi 10 juin au 3 juillet au château
de rambouillet